Mexican coke is just so much better real
sugar everything's in Spanish is
beautiful retro bottle it's just better
right right it's just better actually
the reality is no something's going on
with Mexican coke and I need to tell you
about it by the way this video is
sponsored by Squarespace which I will
tell you about at the end of the video
ice cold coca-cola a quality product
made with the best of material
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're here in our little cabin which
is actually an 1800s church see the
picture of Jesus right there that we've
turned into an air B&B that you can rent
out if you want but I'm here to talk
about coke so let me sit here on this
old church pew who tell you what I've
learned about this Mexican Coke over the
past few days of sitting here in
isolation is this really Mexican coke I
mean it says at joy may heat go on it so
it's gotta be Mexican coke right nothing
else gives you the bracing Sparkle and
the bright little lifts that so
delightful of yours and ice-cold
coca-cola first off let's talk about
what coca-cola even is and why there's a
difference between US coke and Mexican
coke I mean coca-cola is like this giant
international company that is known for
having a secret recipe that they export
to every corner of the globe so why is
there a difference between Coca Cola's
[Music]
I mean let's go straight to the source
of all knowledge Wikipedia right the
drinks name refers to its original
ingredients coca leaves and Kola nuts a
source of caffeine wait what coca leaves
I know coca leaves but only because I
rode with a bunch of anti-narcotic
police in a helicopter over coca fields
in Colombia busting people for cocaine
production for an episode of Vox borders
these are the people who are growing
coca leaves yes indeed the original Coca
Cola recipe included coca leaves which
is the derivative that is used to make
cocaine but don't worry your bottle of
coke doesn't include any coca leaves
today or maybe it does or no one really
knows because no one actually knows the
recipe this is not a conspiracy video
about cocaine being in your coke I'm
interested in another ingredient that is
inside of this bottle and it's the
sweetener it's made out of sugar sugar
sugar sugar cane sugar it's made with
better ingredients
originally all coca-cola was sweetened
with the same thing straight-up sugar or
what it's chemically known as sucrose
but then a few things happened in the
United States that change that first the
US government got really aggressive
about giving money to US farmers to keep
them profitable so they started pouring
a lot of money into corn subsidizing
corn farmers in the United States you
can see this very clearly in our country
there are entire states that are
basically one giant cornfield so if
you're a corn farmer in the 1980s you
have every incentive in the world to
just produce loads of corn as much as
your soil can possibly eke out
unsurprisingly what this means is that
you have a major surplus of corn loads
of corn everywhere way too much corn
just spilling out of every corner of the
United States at the same time the u.s.
is putting up trade barriers basically
tariffs for sugar coming in from other
countries so sugar became expensive corn
became incredibly cheap and so
businesses like coca-cola did what
businesses do and they rejiggered
everything to find the cheapest possible
option and this is when they turned to a
newly invented sweetener that came from
corn and tasted sweet like sugar but was
chemically very different sugar is
sucrose that's it's kind of chemical
name this new corn sweetener was glucose
and fructose but it was still very sweet
but it came from cheap corn when they
started to use that to sweeten their
coca-cola in the United States
enter high-fructose corn syrup did you
know that corn one of America's favorite
foods are used to make America's
favorite serum the wholesome kind of
sweetness that comes from corn look what
happened to high fructose corn syrup
production in the United States versus
sugar in the 80s and 90s high fructose
corn syrup became the obvious choice
because it was way cheaper and coca-cola
started using it to sweeten their drinks
so this is how you get two different
Coca Cola's the United States producing
coke that is made with high fructose
corn syrup and the rest of the world
including Mexico without any of these
trade restrictions and corn subsidies
continuing to use cane sugar to sweeten
their coca-cola and then
the taste wars begin
[Music]
oh it's Nurse Joy got a natural therapy
soon Mexican coke became a delicacy in
the United States it was only sent to
places that had big Mexican populations
or other immigrant populations that were
used to this cane sugar coke and so it
became rare and hard to find and obscure
not surprisingly hipsters like me got
really into it it was authentic and it
was the original recipe and it was hard
to find and it was in this retro glass
bottle I felt like some commodity was
being like sent from the other side of
the border in this kind of renegade way
and we were getting in on it it tastes
so much better with that cane sugar oh
my god she's having much smoother more
delicious taste so much better so much
better
but wait this is where it starts to get
really weird in 2010 a group of legit
scientists get together to do a
legitimate experiment for a legitimate
science journal and they want to test
soft drinks including Coca Cola they
want to know what sorts of sweetener are
being used for each and how much of that
sweetener is in each of them so they
gather a bunch of soft drinks including
a Mexican Coca Cola and an American Coca
Cola and they do all of their testing
and what they find is that the Mexican
Coca Cola actually has no sucrose in it
meaning sugar all they find in this is
glucose and fructose the elements that
are used to build high fructose corn
syrup what in the Mexican Coke that came
from a Latino market in East LA they
found no sugar they only found the
elements for high fructose corn syrup
what is happening this is supposed to be
sugar it it says on that ingredients of
sugar but it tastes so much better it's
different it
so much better
better it gets weirder
in 2013 Mexican lawmakers became very
concerned with the obesity rate in
Mexico which is considered by public
health officials as quote the fattest
country in the world not my words
there's Mexico has a big obesity problem
and one of the links to that is the
massive amount of sugar that is consumed
Mexican legislators slapped on a tax for
soda all soda was gonna be subject to
attacks which made it more expensive to
produce which sent coca-cola looking for
cheaper options to bottle their coke and
cheaper options equal high fructose corn
syrup as of 2013
ok we're talking like seven years ago
more and more bottlers of Coca Cola in
Mexico serving Mexican markets are using
high fructose corn syrup to sweeten
their coca-cola and selling it in Mexico
so now even legitimate Mexican Coke is
not even Mexican coke anymore it's the
identical to the high fructose corn
syrup stuff you buy here
one of the main bottlers came out and
said don't worry we're going to continue
to send cane sugar coke to the United
States because we know that people
really like it in the United States and
will continue to send it because it's
good business for us to keep making it
with cane sugar but I don't even believe
that guy because of that study remember
the study that said no sucrose only
glucose and fructose
I eat high fructose corn syrup I don't
believe you Mexican bottler I don't
believe that you're sending us cane
sugar coca cola anymore not surprisingly
coca cola has caught on to this idea
that people like me love Mexican coke
and they've totally leaned into it
they've created these gimmicky branding
that's like a Cho and Mexico here it is
here's the offending product bought it
at Target it's just sitting here being
so tokenizing of Mexican aesthetic and
culture okay back to it authentic
original flavors and they've really
leaned into it because they know that
there's a cult following of people like
me who will pay more money okay so I've
been social distancing out here in this
cabin in the woods for like two weeks
oh you've been reading way too much
about the coca-cola bottling industry
and it is completely shattered my
identity as a Mexican coke drinker one
because there's probably not even sugar
in this and two because Mexicans don't
even drink Mexican coke anymore they
drink high fructose corn syrup cool I
guess there is still one reason why I
would drink Mexican coke because it
still comes in this cool retro glass
bottle that makes me feel really cool
about myself and that is why I will
continue to drink it thank you
and now let me sit by my wood-burning
stove and tell you about Squarespace
that is a website builder but it's more
than a website builder and I'm
discovering as I build my own website it
is a giant ecosystem of tools that you
can use to do a lot of things on the
internet from blogging tools to email
marketing tools to support and back and
forth communication tools to just
building a beautiful
website Squarespace has a huge suite of
tools and features that will allow you
you should kind of do whatever you need
to do on the Internet it integrates very
nicely with all sorts of social
platforms as well as like I said email
marketing campaigns which is really
important stuff for a business so you
should go check this out head to
squarespace.com slash Johnny Harris for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch you'll get 10% off your website
or domain service so that you can try
this out and see if it fits your
business Squarespace is really good at
this they have amazing support they've
got lots of tools lots of features I'm
excited to continue to learn more about
all of these features as I dig in and
create my own site with them Thank You
Squarespace for sponsoring this video
and thank you all for watching about
Mexican Coke or should we just say
coca-cola because it's not Mexican coke
Mexican coke is a lie
[Music]